so where do you find lots of neutrons in
the universe or it's neutron stars right
neutron stars form
in the making of supernovae of the
explosions
okay so maybe some of this heavy
material gets sort of made in the making
of the Supernova explosion and then gets
expelled
or you have neutron stars so the you
know if the neutron star survive I mean
usually that's the leftover of the
Supernova if you have two from a binary
pair so Stars usually actually show up
in pairs and so it's not too unusual to
um create a pair of of neutron stars
that will still orbit each other after
both of their progenitor Styles have
exploded
and those two neutrons cells will orbit
each other diligently but as we know now
thanks to ligo the gravitational wave
Observatory
I mean we know already that before but
now has been measured by ligo is that
these two neutron stars they will orbit
each other for like forever but in the
process they will they will lose energy
so that that orbit is what we call the
orbit decays and eventually the two
Neutron cells will merge and that
results in a in an explosive event that
has roughly the energy of a supernova
but uh the process is completely
different and the cool thing is when
these two neutron stars collide they
produce a gravitational wave signature
because neutron stars are super dense
objects they are like giant atomic
nucleuses so there's a lot of
interesting physics happening already
and so if you basically form a super
neutron star by Smashing two into each
other
uh more interesting physics happens and
that means that there's this Ripple sent
out you know into the space uh the you
know the space-time Continuum basically
you know the what do people say the the
ripples of space-time you know it's like
yes it's like you drop a rock into water
right you see the waves coming so that's
exactly what happens when two two
neutron stars emerge and this is
Neutron's Galore right it's really
violent to smash two neutron stars you
know so that are so dense already into
each other
and um they in in 2017 one of these
events occurred and the ligo and Virgo
gravitational wave observatories they
detected that and then the astronomers
pointed their telescopes in that
direction and they indeed observed what
we call the electromagnetic counterpart
so there was something seen in the sky
that faded over the course of two weeks
and that's light curve that light was
exactly
what you get when you create all these
heavy Neutron Rich nuclei in the r
process and then the neutron flux stops
and then it takes about two or three
weeks for most of them of these nuclear
2 DK2 stability
so we saw the astronomer saw in this
electromagnetic counterpart
the nucleosynthesis of heavy elements
occurring
and that's that's just that's amazing
awesome so that's awesome that's
electromagnetic counterpart to the
gravitational waves that were detected
with yes two neutron stars colliding
aggressively violently to create us
super neutron star and that's where you
get all the neutrons and neutron flux
somehow and then that the whole shebang
that happens in two seconds and creates
a bunch of so that confirmed that one of
the sites for sure is for the r process
to occur as neutron star mergers
interestingly enough I have to mention
this here A year prior in 2016. my
former graduate student Alex G and I we
discovered a small dwarf Galaxy
that is currently orbiting the Milky Way
it's called reticulum two that was full
of ancient iron deficient stars that
also had a strong signature of these
heavy elements exactly like he1523
we weren't looking for that I actually
wanted to prove that they had really low
levels of heavy elements because that's
what we had seen in all the other dwarf
galaxies
and I was dead set on showing yet that
that is yet the case again and that that
is a typical signature of early star
formation we already talked about low
strontium and barium abundances and the
oldest Stars right this is what we had
seen anecdotally in in the ancient dwarf
galaxies that are surrounding us so
that's an ancient dwarf Galaxy that that
work actually has a bunch of ancient
stars in it yes
and so now we find reticulum 2 and it
has these the Stars show the signature
of the rapid Neutron capture process the
r process and we elect
okay these stars are located in a dwarf
Galaxy right now we have environmental
information they are not lost in the
Galaxy where we don't know where they
actually came from now we know these
stars were formed in that Galaxy because
they're still in it and that we already
deduced from that that it must have been
a neutron star merger that went off in
reticulum 2 at Early times that polluted
the gas from which all our little stars
formed